I came to this whoops man I came to this
video playing another otter this is
Thailand right what deck thailand yeah
and it's playing in the c3 Sicilian not
to to inspiring okay I had this g6 lied
earlier and then it was quite
interesting hmm yeah this is a way to
play of course it's just recapture night
a 3 B 5 yeah I'm very very much behind a
development bishops III is a super
greedy move here and probably not
working at all a six week and physics I
hope that this doesn't get me at the end
okay at least I'm still on the ball okay
now i can play be five I think yeah come
on b5
all this must be cautious simply because
of a for Bishop Bishop only three sm
piece that you can arrest I try to
arrest this Bishop age 6 yeah I can I
can cover it so Knight to f4 now or not
before is hanging then yeah probably
also try to get the to Bishop calendar I
got it me so um should I play a 5 or
just rookie 8 this is an interesting
decision if I firm is of course a nice
smooth using the extra porn in the
center yeah I should I should do that I
think
Quincy 6 always like the smooth setting
up this battery cannot take a fire
because of the mate and the Queen also
is da for porn so that you're not easily
can play a form therefore pointer and so
I'm before E for an ID for is probably
still valid yeah put it here and now
this was very quickly played and I'm not
sure that white really wants answer to
do that here now this was this is very
nice already III now I can also pick up
be too but III must be the writin's
opening up the the diagonal
I want the utmost activity for for the
pieces
game I him he needs to take it it
doesn't take it and interesting okay i
can just redemption
so so look III is not possible g2 is
protected by the tonight so it's not a
straight down we know anything oh ok but
maybe just take here first and now this
should give for the fall yeah cannot pay
night c 2i just take that so I'm
threatening rookie 3-yard and also have
look 18 as a possible move aha I didn't
really appreciate that one maybe I
should have came try to
exchange him a 2 is still on still a
weak spot
who came
hmm all kinds of material hanging now
and yeah I'm not sure that this was
technically the best way to play but did
I hit it was this was helpful white
resigned yum idea was rue k2 after some
other move in fact it looks around the
bed for white now that I think of it
something like that it's quite quite
convincing yeah I have two bishops and
to have this really strong diagonal so
this should be worth something maybe
this was premature but don't know yeah
it feels like black should be should be
alright yeah I'm getting back III and
possibly a chew on top and I still have
this strong bishop so pretty nice
position I don't know if this opening is
really a really good in this in this
exact fashion because I'm so much down
on on development here in this position
by the way this is a instead of a six
this is a very tiny move check but
cannot really believe that black can't
afford that but maybe there is no direct
refutation but you simply don't do
things like that if you're not a
computer yeah white has tremendous ideas
maybe maybe further che then castles are
then this one I also don't have a dark
square Bishop somewhere dark squares I
really think so not a good idea alright
thanks for watching